(lively piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are,
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(uptempo music)
(upbeat music)
- My lab is primarily interested in
understanding some of the
molecular and cellular basis
for the development of the cortex.
But unlike some of the previous speakers,
we're focusing on the development
of neuronal connectivity
and how circuits assemble
basically in the developing brain.
And so, I'm gonna move
fast on the introduction
because I think you've heard a lot about
the general interest of
understanding what makes us human
and in particular, what makes
our brain human-specific.
Another way to phrase that question
as you heard before is to ask,
what happened to our
genome since we diverged
from our common ancestor more
than seven, 10 millions years,
there's actually debate about
that exact time for divergence
from our common ancestor.
So, to the first question,
what makes our brain human-specific?
You have heard a lot today about
the possibility that what makes our brain
different from our most
common living relatives
like chimps and bonobos,
or to other higher mammals,
would be brain size
or at least the size of the cortex
relative to the rest of the brain.
I would argue that despite the
fact that that's the question
that most people are interested in,
it cannot be the entire
answer for a simple reason.
Which is that if you look
at brain size expansion
including increases in neocortical size,
many mammals have succeeded at this
without any real gain
in cognitive abilities.
In fact, brain size is best
correlated to body size
not to cognitive abilities, right?
So, brain size and neocortex expansion
were probably an important
step during evolution
and it happened many times
during mammalian evolution
but it can't be the only explanation for
what makes our brain human-specific,
at least in emergence
of cognitive abilities.
Many are open remaining possibilities,
neuronal composition, right?
That the type of neurons that are produced
that Rick and others have
talked about earlier.
Circuit connectivity, the
total number of synapses
made between neurons are things that
will influence circuit function
and probably cognitive abilities.
Something that very few
people have talked about,
non-neuronal cells, astrocytes, microglia.
There's actually some very recent evidence
suggesting that differences in composition
or total number of non-neuronal cells
might be different between human
and non-human primate.
So today I'm gonna try to convince you
that we have evidence,
probably the first evidence
suggesting that a specific
gene duplication event
has pretty significantly changed
both the number of synapses
made between neurons,
and we think actually affects
circuit connectivity and circuit function.
So, how did we get
interested in this question?
We got interested in this question
based on the work of
several groups including
a beautiful work from Evan
Eichler that you'll hear about
just after me so I'm not
gonna bore you with details
about what Evan did.
But back in early 2000s
work from Jim Sikela
and then refined and expanded by Evan
identified gene duplication events
that are specific to the human lineage.
Gene duplications, new gene
copies that are not present
in any other non-human primates
or in any other mammals.
So essentially what Evan has shown,
shown here on this graph.
So what Evan has shown is that
in humans you have a whole list of gene,
about 30 genes that have
extra copies essentially.
Those copies are specific to humans,
they're not found in non-human primates.
And unfortunately or fortunately for us,
most of those genes have
completely unknown function.
That's not entirely true.
There is one gene in that list,
SMN1 which is the gene that's mutated
in spinal muscular atrophy.
Turns out that humans and humans only
have an extra copy of this
and it's actually
absolutely fascinating work
that's been done on this.
There's a drug treatment that
just emerged very recently
actually taking advantage
of the second copy,
the human specific copy of SMN1.
If you're interested I
can tell you more about.
But for the vast majority,
all the other genes
have largely unknown function.
And so, except that around the time when
this first work was published,
there was one gene in that list,
SRGAP2 listed here,
that we were probably the only lab working
on this gene at that time.
And we had some interesting data
suggesting that this gene was actually
playing important functions
during brain development,
at least the ancestral copy of this gene.
But when Jim Sikela and Evan
Eichler published these results
were struck by the fact that there are
human-specific copies of this gene.
And so, we embarked on
trying to characterize
what those human-specific
duplications of SRGAP2 do.
So as a paradigm basically
many questions arise from
from this observation
that there are human specific
gene duplicates for those.
The first one is which of those genes
are expressed in the human brain?
Second question is what is the function of
the ancestral copy of these genes?
I mentioned most of those genes
have completely unknown function
during brain development
so we had to start with this.
And the third question
that's truly interesting is,
is the function of the
human specific paralogs
related to the function
of the ancestral copy?
Or are those new copies basically
acquiring some completely
independent function,
some completely new functions
independent of the function
of the ancestral copy, right?
Both scenarios could be true.
So I'm gonna summarize here essentially
about 11 years of work from my lab,
from multiple people in my lab.
And then during the rest of the talk
I'm gonna unpack and
tell you a bit more about
how we got to those conclusions.
So essentially SRGAP2A
is an adapter protein
containing three functional domains.
This bottom end which is essentially
a homodimerization motif.
A central domain called the RapGAP domain.
It's a domain that inactivates
small GTPas called Rac1.
And an SH3 domain that's essentially
a protein-protein interaction motif.
All mammals from rodents
to non-human primates
and humans have this gene.
It's expressed, it's highly
expressed in the brain,
it's expressed largely in only in neurons
and as I'll show you later on,
it's actually very unreached at synapses.
But it turns out that about
two to four million years ago,
two gene duplication events at least
made this new copy that's
human-specific emerge,
that we had to call SRGAP2C.
And Evan will probably tell
you a bit more about that.
And so, this coding sequence
is truncated actually,
it doesn't express the
full-length protein.
It's truncated, it expresses
90% of this bottom end
which remains able to
bind to the ancestral copy
and largely inhibit its function, okay?
So its main function, so it turns out that
we get essentially the same phenotype
when we inactivate the SRGAP2A
or when we induce the
expression of this gene, okay?
And the phenotypes, we
get our delayed excitatory
and inhibitory synaptic maturation,
this phenomenon called neoteny,
which is essentially defined by
retention of immature features
for longer periods of
time during development.
We get increased density of both
excitatory and inhibitory synapses.
And finally, we get increased
cortical connectivity.
This is largely unpublished,
probably won't have time to
tell you much about this.
So, how did we reach these conclusions?
So the first thing that we
did a long time ago in 2009,
we published expression pattern for SRGAP2
and this very simple
observation that the protein
in mouse cortex is expressed
actually peaks at P1
but is expressed largely at postnatal time
when between, during the first
two weeks of postnatal life
when the animals are basically
forming a lot of synapses.
And so, when this very talented postdoc,
Cecile Charrier, joined the lab,
she discovered that in fact SRGAP2 protein
is very unreached at synapses.
This is high-resolution images
of individual synapses in mouse neurons
and I hope you can
appreciate the fact that
essentially there is very
little SRGAP2 in small synapses
and lots of SRGAP2
protein in large synapses.
Those synapses here are visualized,
those excitatory synapses are visualized
by this protein Homer1.
And it turns out that at that time
we didn't know but in
fact those two proteins
in function interact.
So, what is SRGAP2 function
in synaptic development?
So, neurons are absolutely amazing cells
if you think about it, right?
Those cells are gigantic.
A fibroblast that people
have talked about before
would be the size of this
cell body here, right?
So they're gigantic cells
and a graduate student
in the lab, Dan Iascone,
has developed some new
methodology to actually
at single cell resolution in vivo
visualize the presence and the topography
of all synapses, excitatory
and inhibitory synapses,
made into a single neuron, okay?
And so, this allows us to understand both
to have very quantitative ideas of
where synapses are localized in neurons,
how many they form,
and you know, for a
typical neuron like this,
this layer two, three pyramidal
neurons in the mouse forms
somewhere between 4,000 and
6,000 excitatory synapses.
And somewhere between 1,000
and 1,500 inhibitory synapses, right?
So, staggering numbers
for just a single cell.
And so, if you zoom up on those
green dots that you see here,
those are individual
spines, dendritic spines.
I'm gonna talk a lot about
those in the rest of the talk.
Those protrusions, those micron,
the scale is a one micron here.
They're tiny protrusions.
They essentially constitutes
individual synapses,
if you look at an EM picture
of a single spine like this,
these protrusions, this
is the site basically.
A single spine constitute
a single synapse,
it's the postsynaptic receiving
end basically of a synapse
so this is an axon with those
neurotransmitter-filled vesicles here
that release neurotransmitter
in the synaptic cleft,
that then activates
postsynaptic receptors here.
So, essentially those
synapses are the basis
for neuronal communications, right?
And decades of work by hundreds of labs
have identified essentially
a zoo of proteins,
hundreds of proteins that are localized
pre and postsynaptically here.
The dendritic spines.
Those proteins, the main
job of those proteins
including this Homer/Shank
interacting proteins,
I'm gonna tell you in a second,
is to basically create
a very complex scaffold
to anchor and stabilize the
neurotransmitter receptors here
that sense neurotransmitter release here.
And so, we discovered that SRGAP2 look
is actually directly
interacting with Homer here,
and in fact I'll show you later on
SRGAP2 seems to control
the scaffolding properties
of those proteins and controls
the rate of accumulation
of those neurotransmitter receptors
such as AMPA receptors during development.
So how did we discover this?
Takayuki Sassa, the first postdoc
who was involved in this
project started by making
a knockout for SRGAP2A for
the ancestral copy in mice.
So, we made this knockout in order to ask
what happens when we delete this gene?
And the main thing that happens
when you delete this gene
is essentially that if
you look at those spines,
the size of the spines I forgot to mention
is proportional to how mature it is,
how many postsynaptic receptors
have accumulated there.
If you look at an animal
three weeks after birth,
a wild-type animal,
those spines are already mature.
So they have mature synapses.
There's a lot of data that has shown this.
But then if you look at the heterozygous,
so if you delete one copy
or two copies of the gene,
you have significantly smaller spines
at this juvenile time point.
They have longer necks.
So the neck that connects the spine head
to the dendrites is longer,
and most interestingly,
there's a pretty significant
increase in density of those spines.
But interestingly enough this
size effect is transient.
So if you look at P65 at 40 days later,
those spines reach maturation.
So it's just a delay in maturation.
Those spines when you inactivate SRGAP2
seems to be much slower
at reaching maturation.
Instead of being mature at P21
they're mature at P45.
But in the adult basically
the spines remain
having a longer neck
and very significantly
higher numbers basically,
very higher, significantly higher that.
So what happens if we
humanize mouse neurons
for SRGAP2C, right?
I briefly mentioned before
that our model based on
studies we published before
was that the truncated version,
the human-specific version of this gene
would bind to and inhibit the function
of the ancestral copy, right?
So the prediction would be
that if we express
SRGAP2C in a mouse neuron
that expresses SRGAP2A,
we would get phenotype that
look exactly like this, right?
And that's exactly what we found.
Essentially if you look at
juvenile animals control
or SRAGP2C humanized mouse neurons,
you get this delayed maturation, right,
but they actually reach maturation at P65
instead of P21.
And they retain longer necks
and higher spine density.
So this was a very interesting
result for us, right?
This is because essentially we know
that those three features
delayed maturation, a longer neck
which actually has very
important function,
and a higher density are three phenotypes
that are known to
characterize human neurons
compared to either mouse
neurons or non-human primates.
So beautiful work from Javier
DeFelipe, Rafael Yuste,
my colleague at Columbia,
have shown that if you look
at spine density for example
between human or non-human primates,
or if you look at spine density
between human and mouse neurons,
you essentially get 30% to 50%
more dense, higher density of spines
and those spines have longer necks.
And we also know that
synaptic development in humans
is profoundly neotenic.
So basically very prolonged maturation,
very delayed maturation.
So this is interesting, right?
Essentially with just
introducing a single gene
that's human specific in mouse neurons,
we've seen a copy three major aspect
of synaptic development.
Delayed maturation, higher density
and change in the morphology
of those spines, right?
But we have a problem which is that
we know that changing and increasing
the density of excitatory synapses
cannot be the only explanation
since beautiful work from
Javier DeFelipe and many others
have shown that there is an
amazing degree of conservation
in the ratio between excitatory
and inhibitory synapses
in the cortex, right?
So, we know that if SRGAP2,
if that's the only thing SRGAP2 is doing,
increasing the number
of excitatory synapses,
we would have a problem, right?
We would have a major imbalance
between excitation, inhibition
which is the landmark of many
neurodevelopmental disorders for example
such as autism or epilepsy.
So either SRGAP2 was doing the job
and was coordinating the maturation
of both excitatory and inhibitory synapses
or some other genes,
maybe some of the other gene duplications
that I mentioned before would do the job.
It turns out that nature
has selected SRGAP2
probably for a reason.
It's because SRGAP2 does
exactly the same thing
it does at excitatory synapses
and inhibitory synapses.
So we discovered this
because more recently
because now we can actually visualize
inhibitory synapses with amazing accuracy
using for example this gephyrin GFP.
Gephyrin is a protein
that's exclusively localized
at inhibitory synapses.
And using single cell technology,
single cell genetic labeling technology
we can not only visualize with
submicron precision spines,
we can actually localize
those inhibitory blue tones
either the ones that are made
on the dendrite shaft here
or even more rare blue
tones that are made directly
on spine heads here.
I can tell you more about this later on.
And remarkably, we find
that the same thing happens
then for spines if you look
at inhibitory blue tone,
if you down regulate
SRGAP2A, the ancestral copy,
or you introduce and humanize mass neurons
for SRGAP2C expression,
you get higher density
of inhibitory clusters.
Those inhibitory synapses
are much smaller early on
but ultimately reach maturation at P65.
And there's a change in
their actual localization,
the striking increase in the one,
the inhibitory synapses made on
through the spine heads here.
So increased density
and delayed maturation.
It's pretty remarkable.
In fact, if you plot the normalized
increasing density for spines
and for inhibitory
synapses between control
and humanized mouse neurons,
we get remarkably similar effects, right?
So the conclusion here is that
nature has selected the
gene duplication event
that of a gene that essentially controls
the co-evolution of inhibitory
and excitatory synapses, right?
This is really I think a very important
take-home message here.
So, I will finish here by taking a minute
to recap everything I told you today.
We've identified a gene and SRGAP2A
which in its ancestral form
expressed in all mammals
controls three very important
aspect of synaptic development.
It controls the density of
excitatory inhibitory synapses
through work, I didn't
have time to show you.
We were actually able to do
structure function analysis
in vivo using gene replacement strategies.
And so, we can actually dissociate
how SRGAP2 regulate spine density
and inhibitory synapse density
from how it controls the maturation
of excitatory or inhibitory synapses.
And we discovered that the
human specific copy of this gene
which is this truncated form
which remains able to
bind to the ancestral copy
and inhibit its function
inhibits all three
major functions of SRGAP2, right?
So what are the future
directions on this project?
So, there are three future directions.
The first one is what are
the upstream regulator
of this protein?
I didn't tell you anything
about how this gene is regulated
and how the protein itself is regulated.
We have some evidence of
what's upstream of this.
The second very important question is,
where are these increased
number of connections
coming from, right?
So this gene basically,
the emergence of this humans-specific copy
increases the total number of synapses
by 30% or 40% which is very significant.
Where are those connections
coming from, right?
We have some ideas about this already.
And finally probably the most important is
what aspect of circuit function
has been affected by the emergence
of this human-specific copy?
That's something that's much
more difficult to approach
but believe it or not,
we actually have some very
interesting results about this.
So finally, the people who did the work.
The work was largely carried out
by a very talented postdoc
in my lab, Cecile Charrier,
who now has her own lab
at Ecole Normale Superieure
in Paris in France.
But she was assisted by many people
and many people in my lab,
at least those four people listed here
are involved in current
aspect of the project.
And finally I'm excited
since I moved to Columbia
about four years ago,
Columbia is creating a
third campus actually
called Manhattanville,
and very recently we went
from an architectural sketch
to an actual building
that will host 55 labs,
about a thousand people.
So, the Zuckerman Mind
Brain Behavior Institute.
We're very excited to
move into this building
hopefully this fall.
Thank you for your attention.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)